The Joe Rogan Experience so what has
changed in terms of our understanding
the the web has been in the in the
million mile orbit or however away it is
for how long now all right well it got
there and then we did some engineering
so I I guess a year year and a half yeah
and what has changed in our
understanding so that's that's been
people's first question and what I want
to do is temper that to say something a
little different
so yes we expect James Webb to make
great discoveries we expect that but the
first order of business
is hardly ever let's discover something
new today it's here's something that we
have limited understanding of let's
improve on that
and in so doing we deepen our
understanding of how things work in the
universe that doesn't always involve
overturning a previous idea or
discovering something that nobody
ordered all right that will happen we
fully expect that to happen but we
targeted parts of the sky initially
because we know other telescopes have
gone there before and we're going to say
how can we further advance and deepen
our understanding one thing it's going
to be able to do and it has already done
we have you know how many exoplanets
there are I don't know how many of your
audience was born
after 1995.
how many 27 year olds and younger
probably quite a few quite a few okay so
I will take this opportunity to Knight
them Generation X so Planet
1995. I was the first exoplanet
discovered a planet orbiting another
star and uh I'll never forget that
because it was my first time on National
Television I was freshly Minted as
director of the Hayden planetarium in
New York City and NBC Center uh New York
City is the media News headquarters
right of all the networks so NBC sent an
action cam they interviewed me because
of my title not because they knew or
gave it crap who I was my title was
director of the planetarium and so I
gave my best professorial reply I said
was the Doppler shift this is how it's
discovered and what we do and how we
measure it and
and I was describing the fact that when
you discover these planets you don't
actually see the planet you see the
effect of the planet's gravity on the
host star
and so if you'd watch the host star the
host star like jiggles
okay just a little bit in response to
the planet going back and forth around
it so you're measuring the star so I
motioned that like with my hips and that
evening on the evening news
that's all they showed was me jiggling
my hips I said oh my gosh oh okay that's
how that's how to do this
hey you want me to be Professor Neil you
want me to be sound bite meal all right
so from then on I practice my sound
bites and a sound bites like three
sentences oh so you recognize that this
is the format now correct yeah and I
said I I can't just give them my stump
speech as a professor of astrophysics it
has to work in their medium and I and so
I went home and stood in front of the
mirror
and had people just shout out things to
me anything in the universe any idea
object person place or thing and I would
come up with like three sentences that
are interesting make you smile and be
tasty enough to want to tell someone
else the anatomy of a sound bite so try
it say anything in the whole universe
how do we know how just one word just
okay say anything the big bang big bang
the birth of space-time energy
and everything we know and love about
this universe
occurred 14 billion years ago
and we have no idea what happened before
it
and we're still expanding as we will
forever I read an article that's my
sound bite that's a good bang it's a
good sound bite yeah I read an article
about the web telescope and the what
they were taking into consideration is
the possibility that the Big Bang may be
incorrect and that the Universe might be
larger and older than we think
so I I hesitate to ask what pages on the
internet you hang out on it was a like a
legit it wasn't saying the universe is
older and saying as more data and new
information comes in there is a distinct
possibility that the Big Bang might just
be the it just might explain the reach
of the technology and not the actual
Scale of the Universe itself okay so the
way to think about this is
and this is the way science has worked
since basically the year 1600 where
Galileo sort of starts codifying what
people knew probably should be happening
but no one really did it in large scale
if you have an idea about something then
you test it multiple ways and get other
people to test it and if the tests give
you consistent results you have a new
understanding of the universe when that
happens
that knowledge of the universe doesn't
go away it doesn't get undone
what happens typically is you have a
deeper understanding of the universe in
which that understanding gets embedded
and you realize that you only understood
a small part of a larger whole but the
small parts you did understand where you
had multiple experiments that confirmed
it that doesn't change
so the the cleanest example of this and
I'll get back to your question is
Newton's laws of motion and gravity
he you know did anyone
see anything move faster than a
galloping horse in his day probably not
and so the news laws of motion and
gravity worked
they worked not only for galloping
horses it worked for the moon in orbit
around the Earth
and the Earth in orbit around the Sun
and Jupiter's moons in orbit around
Jupiter all right and for the planets
so
okay but wait a minute it doesn't work
for mercury
Mercury's orbit is not following
Newton's Laws is something wrong with
the data let's check it data's correct
oh my gosh what's happening Einstein
comes along and says I have a new
understanding of gravity and a new
understanding of motion
and it accounts for this weirdness in
Mercury's orbit what was the weirdness
it just its shape was not exactly what
Newton's laws of gravity would give you
its shape could only be accounted for
when you throw in Einstein's theory of
general relativity why because the Sun's
gravity is so monstrous and Mercury is
orbiting close enough to it that it's
being influenced by extra phenomenon
going on in the universe that's the
product of very high and significant
gravity
and so
so then do we throw Newton out the
window
no actually you know what Newton's laws
are they're what they're what Einstein's
laws look like
when you put in low speeds and low
gravity
if you put in low speeds they become
Newton's Laws
in that limit
Newton's Laws don't stop working where
they used to work we the Apollo to the
Moon used only Newton's Laws because
Einstein didn't matter at those scales
the Moon and Earth and and Rockets we're
not going fast enough for any of that to
matter
but when you start going fast enough you
cannot use Newton's Laws you have to use
a deeper understanding now where does
Einstein take us
you go into the center of a black hole
you get black holes from Einstein
Center black hole is a singularity
all the theories say the matter occupies
zero volume
thereby having infinite density and
that's kind of weird what no you can't
have infinite no
that's a limit
of Einstein's theory that's where it
breaks down it's some joke that's where
God divides by zero remember in math
class you can't divide by zero right
it's not not defined or not allowed so
in Einstein's equations we're dividing
by zero at the singularity so we all
know
that is brilliant as Einstein was and as
successful as his general theory of
relativity has been
it has limits and one limit is the
center of a black hole and another limit
is the very birth of the universe itself
the getting back to your question the
Big Bang
so we have top people working on trying
to resolve the singularity problem and
in so doing you get to some ideas that
well maybe our big bang because the big
man's not going to go away all the data
support this so now I've got this big
bang thing okay and
well is this embedded in something
bigger
um
so when you put like quantum physics and
general relativity and you try to come
up with some bigger understanding deeper
understanding string theorists have been
all into this
you get a Multiverse
we didn't pull that out of our ass that
came out of the equations
so how old is the Multiverse I don't
know it's definitely older than our
universe because it birthed our universe
and it births other universes and it
bursts
the way the equations drive it and
Infinity of universes
this is the idea that maybe there's a
version of us in another yeah where I'm
bald and you got the afro and but
everything else is the same and also a
version where everything's the same
where everything would be the same yes
everything you've ever said has been
said before exactly in the same order
correct there's no reason to presume
that everything in this universe isn't
or hasn't already played out
in the exact way in another one of these
infinite universes and an infinite
number of different ways correct and so
that that is what comes out of the
equations so that makes the big bang a
kind of a small part of a much larger
whole and so yeah we're ready for that
but the fact that the Universe had a
beginning 14 billion years ago and
there's the cosmic microwave background
all of these features
are intact they're not going to all of a
sudden not apply that's my point that's
my long answer tier so this very clean
things that happened 14 billion years
ago what is the predominant theory of
why
so this Multiverse concept gives us a
reason why okay so
um
it's like imagine you're rolling around
in a in a basin okay and you're stable
there you're just fine but then
something kicks you out of the Basin and
you didn't know that there's a huge hill
to roll down after you come out of that
basin but you didn't know that you
thought you everything was just fine you
rolled down that Hill you're gaining
energy
at the bottom of the hill
something stops you
and then where does all that energy go
one of the hypotheses and I'm highly
simplifying here is that the energy
gained by rolling down a hill
and these are energy Hills that would
exist in this sort of higher dimensional
space that we're talking about the at
that energy has to manifest in that
object somehow and it becomes an
explosion and gives birth with enough
energy gives birth to matter uh
everything that we know and love and it
expands because when you concentrate
that much energy in a small spot that's
the only thing you can do I understand
that you're simplifying it but I don't
simplify it in the sense that
um by using this Basin analogy and
rolling down a hill that their their
equations of the energetics of a system
and this is called This is called a um
uh well a false vacuum so you can be in
a place that's not the true bottom
energy state of the system
but you think everything is fine
and but it's not and so
if you move around in among these Hills
and Valleys you end up birthing
universes out the other side and this
Multiverse concept
actually delivers this for you basically
for free that that thought would be that
the Big Bang is just one of many events
that happen in the Multiverse correct
and not only that it could be that other
big bang events
um might have a different a slightly
different laws of physics in it so you
want to watch out for that if you cross
over from one Universe to the other
and the charge on the electron is
slightly different
you could like all your atoms could just
scatter scatter or depress compress into
a pile of goo yeah so take a take
something to test first yeah send a
chicken out there
chicken's getting no respect whatever
happened to guinea pigs well guinea pigs
they're cute and furry yeah oh my gosh